Hello friends and welcome to your
program 3avn today Bible questions and
answers I am idalia Dinsey and you know
I am smiling because the folks in the
panel today make me smile they
intimidate me because they're so smart
but yet they're so humble to teach us so
I praise the Lord for the men that are
at this panel during this program I hope
you have your Bibles grab something to
write with and something to write on or
just turn on your recording on your
phone so you don't forget these answers
but you know I praise the Lord for the
opportunity that we all have to express
our questions
um some are very deep questions and some
are simpler questions but they're all
important questions so we're going to
present in the panel to you today to my
right Jason Bradley Mr Bradley how are
you today I'm doing well it's great to
be here and you know we always pray
first as we study out these answers and
I'm loving it because I'm learning amen
so I've got a lot of growth that needs
to take place and a lot of learning that
needs to take place and so this helps
with that yes but you also have a
teachable spirit too Jason you have
grown so much throughout these years and
I admire you so God bless you continue
to do that and we have James Rafferty
welcome James good to be here always
love Bible q a and like my brother Jason
said it is a time to learn I grow so
much and learn so much these questions
that come in amen well thank you for
what you do for the Lord and for all the
help you've been to all of us
spiritually and my favorite sorry guys
but my very own John Dinsey welcome
thank you so much it's a blessing to be
here and to be able to see you across
uh we can never say that we know it all
we always must come to the reading of
the scriptures with a a teachable spirit
a learning we want to learn from the
Lord and the wonderful thing is that
he's willing to teach each and every one
amen amen just sitting across from you
like this reminds of me of you and I at
the house you know you sit there with
your books and Bible and across from you
and did you know honey or are you ready
for worship or this and that so this is
like natural for us right but anyhow
guys at home are you ready for the
lesson for today I mean some of you guys
sent a text or emails and we are going
to share some of your questions but
before that we'd like to invite you and
to join us in this prayer and asking the
Holy Spirit to be with us as well father
God we come before your throne of grace
thankful father for your word that
teaches us that gives us peace and hope
it gives us the Plan of Salvation so
clear to to some and others who are
learning of the Plan of Salvation I pray
father that through your Holy Spirit
they will understand impress upon their
hearts touch their ears Lord so they can
hear your word and that they can also
study it in their Bibles and I take
somebody's word for it so we ask you
that as we guide our friends at home our
families at home through the answers in
the Bible that they will also continue
their personal study we give you all the
praise and all the glory and honor
please be with each and every one of us
here we pray in Jesus name amen amen
amen okay guys you know what there are
some folks out there saying I want to
send a question man and I forget well
guess what I'm going to share the
contact information where you can send
these questions to and you can send a
text phones are always handy
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 and of course
you can send us an email at bibleqa at
3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn dot TV and
those that like those social media
platforms we do have an Instagram and
it's 3abn underscore official three
that's the number three a b n underscore
official now good students ready we are
ready well guys here we go with the
first question and this is from Gian
from Arizona Arizona and she's sending a
text and Jason Bradley I'm going to ask
you this question were there two
lampstands in the sanctuary in the Holy
place or just one ah well thank you so
much for your question the short answer
is no there weren't two lampstands there
was only one it was found in the Holy
place it was on the left hand side now
there were seven lamps but on one lamp
stand so let's look at Exodus chapter 25
verse 31. you shall also make a
lampstand of pure gold the lamps then
shall be of hammered work its shaft its
branches its bowls its ornamental knobs
and flowers shall be of one piece so we
see from that verse that it was singular
the instructions that God gave for the
construction of the sanctuary were very
meticulous the sanctuary message is
absolutely beautiful as it constantly
points us to Christ and the Plan of
Salvation now during my study of the
lampstand in particular I found a few
things that fascinated me in Exodus
chapter 25 verse 36 7 it says you shall
make seven lamps for it and they shall
arrange its lamps so that they give
light in front of it now why did that
stand out to me here's why Psalm chapter
119 verse 105 says your word is a lamp
to my feet and a light to my path
so the lamp stand is Illuminating the
path before it and you know you think
about God's word and how it illuminates
our path and and the direction that we
should go now in front of the lamp stand
we see the altar of incense right and
that's where Christ intercessory work
takes place
everything is pointing us to Jesus and
his Plan of Salvation for us another
thing that stood out to me was the
intentionality and the level of care
that is needed or required for The
lampstand Exodus chapter 27 verses 20
and 21 it says and you shall command the
children of Israel that they bring you
pure oil of pressed olives for the light
to cause the lamp to burn continually in
the Tabernacle of meeting outside the
veil which is before the testimony Aaron
and his sons shall tend it from evening
until morning before the Lord it shall
be a statute forever to their
Generations on behalf of the children of
Israel so you notice the care that needs
to to take take place there night and
day we need to be in the word of God
night and day we need to be focused on
the Lord and the other thing that really
stood out to me was the fact that you
know it was ham hammered I think it was
one Talent of gold right what's the one
thing that we all have in common we have
24 hours in our day how are we spending
our time we need to be spending our time
serving the lord learning about God and
growing in his likeness amen amen
beautiful thank you thank you so much
our next question comes from Florida
through text I want to thank Colt for
sending it in and the question is can we
as human live a sinless life now James
that is a great question Cole thank you
for asking that question yes the answer
is yes the the simple answer is yes I'm
just going to share with you a few texts
on that job chapter 1 verse one there
was a man in the land of us whose name
was job and his this man was perfect
Matthew 5 48 be therefore perfect as
your father which in heaven is perfect
Romans 8 verse 4 that the righteousness
of the law might be fulfilled and also
walk not after the flesh but after the
spirit for first Peter 4 1 for as much
as Christ has suffered for us in the
flesh arm yourselves with the same mind
for he that has suffered In the Flesh
has ceased from sin wow and then we have
first John chapter 2 verse 1. my little
children these things I write unto you
that you sin not if any man sin we have
an advocate with the father Jesus Christ
the righteous and then Jude verse 24 now
unto him that is able to keep you from
falling and present you faultless before
the presence of his glory with exceeding
joy and then Revelation 14 verse 5 and
in their mouth it was found no guile for
there without fault Before the Throne of
God
so it's clear in the Bible and I wanted
to pick a number of references from all
the different authors you know from Paul
from John from Peter from Jude just so
that we could see that the picture of
the Bible is yes we can be perfect but
the question is not whether it's
possible for us to be perfect or to live
a life without sin the real question we
need to ask is what do people look like
what do perfect people look like right
because we have a false standard of
perfection for example in the Pharisees
the Pharisees thought they were perfect
but they were really judgmental they
were really self-righteous they were
really oppressive right so that's not
really what Perfection looks like all we
need to do is go back now to the context
of a lot of these verses for example the
context of job
God called him perfect why because every
time his children were partying together
he would get up early in the morning and
he would offer burnt offerings for them
and he would intercede in their behalf
because he was afraid they were
forgetting God and they might have
cursed God in their hearts when it says
in Matthew 5 48 be perfect it's talking
about turning the other cheek going the
extra mile he's talking about blessing
those that curse you and praying for
your enemies in Matthew or excuse me in
Jude when it talks about you know being
presented faultless it talks about
people who are trying to reach out to
other people and pull them out of the
fire and be compassionate toward them
and be straight with them and help them
to find the Lord and not only so but
we have this picture of the attitude of
Perfect People what is their attitude
well we find that in Daniel chapter six
and in Revelation chapter 1 in
Philippians chapter 3 and Daniel 6 when
Daniel sees Jesus he says my glory my
goodness my comeliness was turned into
me into corruption and I had no strength
in Revelation when John saw Jesus he
fell down and said dead man and in
Philippians chapter 3 Paul has this
attitude of you know not as though I had
already attained either were already
perfect but I pressed toward the Mark I
forget about those things which are
behind and by the way in the context of
Philippians chapter 3 the things that
Paul is forgetting about are not his
failures they're his attainments that's
why he says not as though I'd already
attained see one of the greatest enemies
to overcoming and being perfect is to
look at our attainments and think that
we've arrived right and so Paul says I
forget about those things in fact when
Paul gets to the very end of his life in
first and second Timothy he's speaking
from jail he's getting ready to be
executed you know what he says
I am the chief of Sinners for I
persecuted the Church of God but I did
it without understanding and God's grace
saved me and he can save you also this
was Paul's attitude so Perfection is
possible but let's make sure we have the
right attitude and we have the right
context so we know what Perfection looks
like and how people act when they really
are close to God Amen Beautiful Lord
help us right amen well John Denver this
next question I'm gonna have you answer
and thank you Teresa for sending in your
question via email it says here I have
recently learned of a new belief called
the luciferian flood and how it claims
that the Earth is indeed millions of
years old I don't believe it personally
but have noticed the growing trend of
people that do could you please explain
whether or not there is any truth to
this John Dempsey thank you for your
question and this is um something that's
coming around again because this has
been around actually it was called The
Gap Theory and also the ruin and
restoration idea or belief and the idea
is that between Genesis chapter 1
and verse 1 and Genesis chapter 1 verse
2 there's a gap of millions and millions
of years now when you read the
scriptures do you see evidence or do you
see that idea there no it's not let's go
ahead and read Genesis chapter 1 verse 1
and 2. in the beginning God created the
heavens and the Earth the Earth was
without form and void and darkness was
on the face of the deep and the spirit
of God was hovering over the face of the
waters so remember that originally the
scriptures were written without Bible
verses
so the idea to insert millions of years
there between Genesis 1 and and two it's
a it's a really bad I'm calling it a bad
and sad attempt by an individual or
individuals to try to adapt a Bible to
what the current belief of the science
uh is because you find fossils and you
find artifacts and they they they try to
date these things and they say well this
thing is 20 million years old 25 50
million years old and they're trying to
find an explanation for this and
somebody came up with this idea so the
idea between this theory is uh that
before Genesis 1 and 2 verse 1 and 2
God created a perfect Earth
and in this perfect Earth Satan Ruled
the Earth or Lucifer Ruled the Earth and
then eventually caused a rebellion and
God to punish him made a flood on the
earth and oh also during this time they
say that the people that lived there
were men without Souls
this is another thing they put in this
the problem with all of this is that uh
there's a Bible version the Thompson
Chain reference Bible they have put this
in the bottom as kind of an explanation
for Genesis 1 and 2. so this created a
problem for people because they're
trying to read the Bible and there are
new people reading the Bible and they
see this and they see it in the bottom
of the Bible and please understand that
the commentaries that are found in a
Bible are there for study helps their
suggestions they don't they're not
inspired let's call it they're not
inspired they're there to try to help
you understand the Bible but they're not
inspired so when you read Genesis 1 and
2 and remember it says and the spirit of
God was hovering over the face of the
waters so the idea that the face of the
waters according to them was a remain
from that flood that the Lord punished
the uh Satan and and and the men without
Souls with so they say that all these
fossils that are millions of years old
are not connected genetically to the
animals and plants of today so this is
all
speculation speculation and we need to
keep away from these things
the Bible tells us notice this very
clear Exodus chapter 8 verse 11. it says
for in six days the Lord made the
heavens and the Earth the sea and all
that is in them and rested the seventh
day therefore the Lord blessed the
Sabbath day and holiday so everything in
this Earth was created in six days
there's no room in the Bible for this
idea that the things in the Earth are
millions and millions of years old and
one of the things they use is Carbon 14
dating to try to date these things and
scientists are now coming out saying
this system of Carbon 14 dating is not
accurate at best it can be accurate to a
few decades or a few years and this
there's more research going on about
this exercise will eventually Exodus
chapter 20 Exodus chapter 20 verse 8
chapter 20 verse 11 verse yeah and so uh
just quickly here science will
eventually catch up to the Bible when
you have to make a choice between
science and the Bible stick with the
Bible because science will eventually
catch up what the Bible says yes thank
you so much great answer
um you know I missed the Bible text
again can you confirm it again that
Exodus Exodus chapter 20 verse 11 4 and
6 days the Lord made the heavens and the
Earth thank you so much thank you all
right another email that we received was
from Catherine and Jason Bradley are you
ready for this next question
this says thank you Catherine does being
fruitful in Christ only require winning
Souls
excellent question Catherine excellent
question being fruitful in Christ does
not only require winning Souls while
evangelism and leading others to Christ
are important aspects of being a
Christian there are other ways to be
fruitful in Christ as well for example
we can bear spiritual fruit in our own
lives by living a life that reflects
Christ's teachings and character now
this includes growing in our faith
practicing the fruits of the spirit and
so much more Galatians Chapter 5 Verse
22 and 23 says but the fruit of the
spirit is love joy peace long-suffering
kindness goodness faithfulness
gentleness self-control against such
there is no law so what else should we
do we need to abide in Christ John
chapter 15 verse 5 says I am the vine
you are the branches he who abides in me
and I in him Bears much fruit for
without me you can do nothing we need to
increase in the knowledge of God and
pray for others Colossians chapter 1
verses 9 and 10.
for this reason we also since we also
since the day we heard it do not cease
to pray for you and to ask that you may
be filled with the knowledge of his will
and all wisdom and spiritual
understanding that you may walk worthy
of the Lord fully pleasing him being
fruitful in every good work and
increasing in the knowledge of God when
we recognize whose we are it determines
what we do Ephesians chapter 2 verse 10
says for we are his workmanship whose
workmanship his workmanship created in
Christ Jesus for good works which God
prepared beforehand that we should walk
in them
additionally we can be fruitful by using
the gifts and talents that God blessed
us with
and helping to build up the church so we
can teach we can preach we can if you
can sing by all means sing I can't sing
so I'm not going to do it but if you can
sing that's great whatever it takes but
use your skills your god-given gifts and
abilities to help those that are in need
and and help build up the church but
there's so many different ways to be
fruitful but we believe that we are
saved by grace through faith in Christ
alone and so it's not a works-based type
of thing so pay attention to those
different ways to be fruitful and go out
there and live and Carry Out The Gospel
amen well said Mr Bradley thank you so
much now this question comes from Sherry
from Pennsylvania thank you for the text
and James will you please answer this
question it says is Zechariah 14 for
history I know Jesus's feet do not touch
the Earth in second coming so what is
this referring to
he's a Sherry from Pennsylvania great
question I appreciate all the questions
you bring in here this one is a good one
too so Zechariah Chapter 14 verse 4.
good point Christ's feet do not touch
the earth when he comes the second time
so what is this referring to well the
text tells us that God is going to
gather the Nations let's just read the
text and we'll read it in its context
Zechariah 14 beginning with verse 2. for
I will gather all the nations against
Jerusalem to battle
I'm going to skip to verse 3 now then
shall the Lord go forth and fight
against those Nations as when he fought
in the day of battle verse 4 and his
feet shall stand in that day upon the
Mount of Olives which is before
Jerusalem on the East and the Mount of
Olives will cleave in the midst thereof
toward the East and toward the west and
there shall be a great valley half the
mountain will move toward the North and
half the mountain will remove toward the
South so we know this is not talking
about the second coming because we're
told in Matthew 24 31 and first
Thessalonians 4 verse 17 that when
Christ comes the second time he gathers
his elect from the four corners of the
earth and we meet him in the air so
Jesus doesn't actually come down to the
Earth but at his third coming which is
talked about also in the Bible in these
verses I believe we just read because
the New Jerusalem City comes down and
we're told that the New Jerusalem City
comes down in Revelation chapter 21
verses 1 through 3. it comes down and it
sits on the Mount of Olives which has
been made into a plateau flattened so
the ninja slim sits there and then we're
told there's going to be a battle that's
going to take place and this battle is
explained
in Revelation chapter 20 when the wicked
are resurrected and they surround the
city of God and in Zechariah here it
says that the Lord is going to fight and
that word fight comes from a primitive
root word which means to feed on or
figuratively to consume right to destroy
by implication when we read about the
after the Thousand Years in Revelation
chapter 20 beginning with verse 7 it
talks about that Satan is loosed out of
his prison for us a little season
meaning he can see people again he goes
forth to deceive the Nations because
they've been resurrected at the second
resurrection and
and Gog and Magog and to bring them to
battle to fight the number of whom is
the sand of the sea and they go up on
the breadth of the earth and they
surround the city and the camp of the
camp of the Saints the Beloved City and
fire comes down from God out of heaven
and devours them the uh easy the ESV
translation says English Standard
Version says consumes them so the same
word that's used there in Zechariah is
used in Revelation chapter 20 concerning
this and of course jute in verses 14 and
15. talk about Enoch also prophesied the
seventh from Adam prophesied of this
saying behold the Lord comes with ten
thousands of his Saints well this is his
third coming what's he coming to do to
execute judgment upon all and to
convince all that are ungodly among them
of all their ungodly teachers they have
ungodly committed and of all their hard
speeches which ungodly Sinners have
spoken against him so this is the third
coming it's after the Millennium when
the wicked are resurrected and and
surround the city the city lays on the
Mount of Olives it's been laid flat
Jesus feet touched their at that time
wow amen how exciting news I can just
feel the excitement okay John then say
Jim sent an email and his question is
the following in the Bible we read about
several Great Men of Faith who had more
than one wife
these men such as Abraham Jacob David
and Solomon were greatly blessed by God
throughout their lives with no mention
that they were sinning by having
multiple wives why isn't polygamy
mentioned as a sin along with
fornication and adultery now what's the
answer Jim wants to know you better
answer
yes many of us want to know
well let's go ahead and go to the Bible
because the Bible tells us about what
should be a marriage it says in Genesis
chapter 1 verse 21-24 and the Lord God
caused a deep sleep to Fallen Adam and
he slept and he took one of his ribs and
closed up the Flesh in its place then
the rib which the Lord God had taken
from man he made into a woman notice
that he made one woman he only took one
made one woman he didn't make many women
and he brought her to the man and Adam
said this is now bone of my bones and
Flesh of My Flesh she shall be called
woman
because she was taken out of man
therefore a man shall leave his father
and mother and be joined to his wife and
they shall become one flesh so it's one
man one woman that can become one flesh
she's not one man and five women one man
and ten a hundred women that can become
one flesh one man and one woman become
one flesh this is God's plan this is the
way God ordained it to be from the very
beginning in fact uh when we look at
Deuteronomy chapter 17 uh verse 17 uh
the context is talking about
uh a king coming over the people of
Israel and the idea is man I this king
is going to have more abundance I can
afford to have more than one wife no the
Lord says in Deuteronomy 17 17 neither
shall he multiply wives for himself
lest his heart be turned away nor shall
he greatly multiply silver and gold for
himself so these scriptures are enough
to help us understand that it is a sin
to depart from that which God has
ordained God has established so the
question is why did it appear to be that
Abraham was blessed and Jacob David and
Solomon the question is would the Lord
have blessed them more if they have
stuck or been faithful to having just
one wife that's the question I would
post to you but take a look at each one
of these cases Abraham
everything was going fine and dandy
let's call it that way fine and dandy is
a thing that people use until Sarah
suggested why don't you take Hagar my
handmade and through her you can have
children was it a wonderful experience
no there was fighting between Sarah and
Hagar and even the son that was born
Ishmael began to criticize uh Isaac that
was born so each one of the cases shows
us that problems multiplied with
multiplying of wives we do not have good
examples we do not have good results
with the multiplication of wives so this
should be enough for us to help us
understand one man one woman one
marriage become one amen amen thank you
so much I want to say that actually it's
Genesis chapter 2 verse 21-24 now
Genesis chapter one okay and the other
reference is Deuteronomy 17 17. okay 17
17 thank you so much all right well we
continue with these questions they have
come in and we want to thank you for
taking the time and sending your
questions so we're waiting for yours too
okay please send them in now this is for
Jason Bradley and we received it from
Delaware through text from Emmanuel and
the question is how do I confess my sins
do I go to church leaders or do I go
directly to the Lord oh Jason this is
such a good question absolutely and it's
a very important question too so I want
to thank you for sending that in amen
when you go to the Lord which is where
you should go go to the Lord no mere
mortal can absolve you of your sins but
go with a sincere heart you know God
looks at the condition of the heart so
go with a sincere heart but I want you
to consider Mark chapter 2 verses 5
through 10. I love this story here when
Jesus saw their faith he said to the
paralytic son your sins are forgiven you
and some of the scribes were sitting
there and reasoning in their hearts or
why does this man speak blasphemies like
this who can forgive sins but God alone
but immediately when Jesus perceived in
his spirit that they reasoned us within
themselves he said to them why do you
reason about these things in your hearts
which is easier to say to the paralytic
your sins are forgiven you or to say
arise take up your bed and walk
but that you may know that the son of
man has power on Earth to forgive sins
we know that when Jesus was on this
Earth he was a hundred percent human and
he was also a hundred percent Divine too
his his divinity was intact as well so
he had the ability to forgive sins and
still has the ability to forgive sins in
John Chapter 14 verse 6 Jesus said to
him I am the way the truth and the life
no one comes to the father except
through me so we see in that verse that
the only way to the father is through
the son through Jesus Christ and so
that's why we end our prayers in Jesus
name in Jesus name amen it's Paramount
to ask God for forgiveness of our sins
but it's also vitally important that we
ask him for the strength to overcome and
so we don't repeat those same sins as
well first Corinthians chapter 10 verse
says no temptation has overtaken you
except such as is common to man but God
is faithful who will not allow you to be
tempted beyond what you are able but
with the Temptation will also make the
way of Escape that you may be able to
Bear it amen in Romans chapter 3 verses
23-26 you're going to love this these
verses right here for all have sinned
and fall short of the glory of God being
justified freely by his grace through
the Redemption that is in Christ Jesus
whom God set forth as a propitiation by
his blood through faith to demonstrate
his righteousness because in his
forbearance God had passed over the sins
that were previously committed to
demonstrate at the present time his
righteousness that he might be just and
the justifier of the one who has faith
in Jesus to sum it all up here's the
process
the Holy Spirit convicts us of our sin
we go to God the Father through Christ
the son
and confess our sins we ask for strength
not to repeat the same sins we turn away
from our sin turn towards God resist the
devil and he will flee from us and go to
God God wants to hear from you first
John chapter 1 verse 9 says if we
confess our sins he is faithful to
forgive us of our sins and to cleanse us
from all or of all
unrighteousness amen amen amen amen
preach it brother
good job thank you thank you so much all
right guys the next question
um James would you please answer this
came in through text from Michigan I
don't have a name here
but the question is why did God need
Jesus to create the world why didn't he
do it himself in reference to Hebrew 1
1-4 good question from Michigan thank
you for that question let's just look at
Hebrews chapter 1 verses 1 through 4. it
says God who at sundry times and in
diverse manage now I'm reading from the
King James The Good Old King James
version sundry and divers we don't know
what that means but it sounds Majestic
and beautiful doesn't it amen spoke in
times past unto the fathers by the
prophets has in these last days spoken
unto us by his son speaking of Jesus
whom he appointed heir of all things and
by whom also he made the worlds who
being the brightness of his glory and
the express image of his person and
upholding All Things by the word of his
power when he had by himself purged our
sins sat down at the right hand of the
Majesty on high and the question was
asked why did God need Jesus to create
the world why didn't he do it himself he
did you see Jesus Is God and that's
really what the first chapter of Hebrews
establishes that Jesus is God we just
read that he is the express image of his
person he's the brightness of his glory
and so when you look at these verses for
example verse 6 and again when he brings
his firstborn into the world he says
that all the angels of God worship Him
Angels can't worship anyone but God you
know John tried to worship an Angel and
the angel said ah don't do that he
probably remembered Lucifer you know and
this is how it all started but the
angels can worship the son because he is
God he is one with the father for
example look at another verse verse 8
speaking of Christ but under the son he
says thy Throne o God is forever and
ever a scepter of righteousness is the
scepter of thy kingdom look at another
verse with me and this is all in Hebrews
chapter 1 verse 10. and thou Lord
speaking of Christ in the beginning has
laid the foundations of the Earth the
heavens are the works of thine hands
again and again in Hebrews chapter 1
Jesus Christ is established as one with
the father so when it says when you ask
the question why didn't God do it
himself he did do it himself because
Jesus this is the Son of God along with
the father and the Holy Spirit they are
the godhead and together they created
the worlds in fact we're told that in
other verses let's just move out of
Hebrews we'll move into chapter one of
the Book of John the Gospel of John
verse 1 says in the beginning was the
word and the Word was with God and the
Word was God the same was in the
beginning with God and all things were
made by him and without him was not
anything made that was made I love that
that's beautiful so Genesis chapter 1 is
basically being referenced here by John
chapter 1 in the beginning God created
the heavens and the Earth so John is
doing another in the beginning he's
referring back to the creations story
and in that creation story he's speaking
specifically about the word who John
goes on to explain was made flesh and
dwelt Among Us Jesus Christ so the
simplest answer to your question is God
did actually create the world himself
and of course we know that because Jesus
Christ is one with the father amen glory
to God thank you so much so those that
came in in the middle of the answer to
that question he was reading Hebrews
chapter 1 1-10 and then John 1 1 and
then Genesis 1 1 is the reference from
creation all right uh John Dempsey are
you ready I am I have the easy part I
get to ask the questions thank you Carla
from Tobago a beautiful country thank
you for the email can you please explain
First Timothy 5 23 and proverbs 21.
very good and the reason why you
mentioned this question Carla is will be
obvious when I read them it says in
first Timothy chapter 5 verse 23 no
longer drink only water but you say
little wine for your stomach's sake and
your frequent infirmities
and Proverbs chapter 20 verse 1 wine is
a mocker strong drink is a brawler and
whoever is Led astray by it is not wise
and it says in the King James version
strong drink is Raging so why uh why
these two apparently contradictions here
this these contradiction uh when you go
into the Old Testament
you will find a few words that are
translated wine when you go into the New
Testament you'll find a few words
translated wine as well in the Hebrew it
is in Greek it is and it's really the
context that help people to understand
if they were referring to
fermented grape juice or unfermented
grape juice it was the context that
helped them to understand and really in
those days they didn't have a
um really practically anything to be
able to protect things from fermenting
quickly so and for you to get the
greater benefit from grape juice you
have to drink it fresh or drink it
quickly so when when you when you go
here and you say well uh why was he told
to drink a little wine for his stomach's
sake
you will find it interesting that uh all
the ancient writers it's interesting
that I found all ancient writers such as
Aristotle athenius and Pliny indicated
that unfermented wine grape juice was
known and preferred to alcoholic wine
for medical purposes very interesting so
it is obvious obvious here that when you
look at Paul and he's trying to help
Timothy with his issue he's not going to
tell him to drink the fermented wine the
fermented juice
and really when you look at a a juice
this is a juice grape juice let's call
it a grape juice okay drink it oh it's
fermented already but it still grapes
it's still it's still wine drink it so
this was the common thought in those
days eventually the manufacturing of
wine became in popular and now the word
the word begins to change I remember
seeing some black and white uh movie a
long time or I came in and and I
somebody was watching and I hear I hear
the ladies say to to somebody some movie
from the 50s or 60s telling somebody
that was at the table oh you're so gay
and this was in the 50s or 60s when the
word gay was not used to refer to
someone that has homosexual tendencies
so words do tend to change so here uh
what Paul is saying hey drink some grape
juice is good for your stomach it's
going to help you out and even modern
science has discovered that it has and
grape juice that has anti-inflammatory
substances that prevent the swelling of
the stomach tissues it also reduces the
symptoms for example having pain and
burning feeling if a person has stomach
infection also it has a relaxation
relaxation Relaxation Station effect
upon the walls of the stomach which
produce the mucus to protect the walls
in turn in turn it boosts the recovery
of the normal state to the pH of the
blood of a person so this is what Paul
was telling Timothy do something to help
your health drink some pure grape juice
thank you very much very clear thank you
all right well I want to quickly just
share the phone number again if I may
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 email bibleqa
at
3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn.tv and you can
send your questions or comments to 3abn
underscore official in our Instagram all
right well right now we have Jason
Bradley who's going to answer the last
question to him and this is from Ghana
it's a text that we received Jason so it
says why did Jesus take his disciples to
meet Moses and Elijah in Luke 9 30.
Moses and Elijah dead
hmm well first off I love the fact that
this question is coming from Ghana does
it shows that the gospel is going around
the world Amen I want to address the
first part of your question where you
stated if Moses and Elijah are dead well
Moses and Elijah Aren't Dead how do we
know this well for Elijah let's look at
second Kings chapter 2 verses 11 through
13. then it happened as they continued
on and talked now this is Elijah
speaking with Elisha that suddenly a
chariot of fire appeared with horses of
fire and separated the two of them and
Elijah went up by a whirlwind Whirlwind
into heaven we see from these verses
that Elijah was taken to heaven without
tasting death going on to verses 12 and
13 and Elisha saw it and he cried out my
father my father The Chariot of Israel
and its Horsemen so he saw him no more
and he took hold of his own clothes and
tore them into two pieces he also took
up the mantle of Elijah that had fallen
from him and went back and stood by the
bank of the Jordan
Elisha witnessed Elijah being taken to
heaven now let's take a look at Moses's
situation found in Jude 9. Yet Michael
the Archangel and contending with the
devil when he disputed about the body of
Moses dared not bring against him a
reviling accusation but said the Lord
rebuke you and then in Luke chapter 9
verse 27 Jesus said but I tell you truly
there are some standing here who shall
not taste death till they see the
kingdom of God now here's where I got
really excited because I don't really go
deep into the Greek and all this other
stuff but I love when I get to hear it
and learn about it and stuff so here we
go the word for Kingdom in Greek is
basalea I believe that's how you
pronounce it basalea now basalea means
royal power kingship Dominion or rule
it's used in the New Testament to refer
to the reign of the Messiah now with
that in mind let's look at verses 28
through 31 of Luke Chapter 9. now it
came to pass about eight days after
these sayings that he took Peter John
and James and went up on the mountain to
pray as he prayed the appearance of his
face was altered and his robe became
White and glistening and behold two men
talked with him who were Moses and
Elijah who appeared in glory and spoke
of his decease which he was about to
accomplish at Jerusalem now deceased
sort of departure
um kind of one in the same they're
interchangeable
this was a type of of the second coming
of Christ Jesus was glorified Moses was
resurrected from the dead representing
that class of people and Elijah
represented those that wouldn't taste
death to further solidify this picture
let's look at first Thessalonians
chapter 4 verses 13 through 17. but I do
not want you to be ignorant Brethren
concerning those who have fallen asleep
lest you sorrow as others who have no
hope for if we believe that Jesus died
and rose again even so God will bring
with him those who sleep in Jesus for
this we say to you by the word of the
Lord that we who are alive and remain
until the coming of the Lord will by no
means precede those who are asleep for
the Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of an
archangel and with the trumpet of God
and the dead in Christ will rise first
then we who are alive and remain shall
be caught up together with them in the
clouds to meet the Lord in the air and
thus we shall always be with the Lord
I'm ready to be with the Lord how about
you amen beautiful
um I'm sorry I put first Thessalonians
chapter 4 verses 13 through 17 through
17. oh the Lord beautiful beautiful okay
guys
um James you ready for your last
question yes all right it says here and
this is from Helen from Kenya and
through Instagram we received this
comment in a question according to
numbers 21 8 then the Lord said to Moses
make a fiery Serpent and set it on a
pole and it shall be that everyone who
is bitten when he looks at it shall live
why did the Lord choose the symbol of a
serpent which according to Revelation
represents devil thus the symbol of the
serpent on the bull also represent Jesus
on the cross Helen wants to know good
question Helen from Kenya this yes I
think you've got it you've nailed it but
well let's just look at this uh we we
know for sure
that this serpent is a symbol of the
devil but we recognize that when Moses
was commanded to do this that the people
who were bitten by serpents actually
lived when they looked to the serpent
the Brazen serpent was put up on that
pole and so we see something here that
indicates the Plan of Salvation now this
all comes together when we read Second
Corinthians chapter 5 specifically verse
21. Second Corinthians chapter 5
beginning with verse 14 talks about how
Jesus Christ's love compels us we become
new creatures in Christ because we're
reconciling him and that he God does not
count our sins against us because Jesus
Christ has become the sacrifice the one
who stood in our place as our substitute
the one who stood in in our place as our
represent representative the second Adam
were told in First Corinthians 15 and so
then he closes out second Corinthians
chapter five with this verse this is
verse 21 this is what he says for he
that's talking about God for he has made
him talking about Christ to be sin for
us who knew no sin that we might be made
the righteousness of God in him now that
is
quite averse you just have to draw a
deep breath there and understand what
God is saying here but he's saying
exactly what we see Moses being told in
the Old Testament story of that Brazen
serpent Jesus Christ becomes the symbol
of sin he becomes the representative of
sin and God actually we're told in
Zechariah 13 verse 7 for example God
says awake o sword against thy Shepherd
God actually takes upon Christ the
punishment that we deserve places upon
Christ the punishment that we deserve we
see this all through the old and the New
Testament Isaiah chapter 53 for example
there are a couple of verses there that
say verse 5 of Isaiah 53 he was wounded
for our transgressions he was bruised
for our iniquities the chastisement of
chastisement of our peace was upon him
and with his stripes we are healed and
then then again it says continuing on
it says that he was made to be sin for
us he was taken from prison from
judgment and who will declare his
generation verse 8 he was cut off from
the land of the living for the
transgression of my people he was
stricken verse 10 yet it pleased the
Lord to bruise him he has put him to
grief when he shall make his soul an
offer him for sin he shall see his seed
he shall prolong his days and the
pleasure of the Lord shall prosper in
his hands so what we're seeing here is
Jesus Christ coming in the likeness of
sinful flesh coming as a human being
taking the place of the first Adam
becoming part of the human race
permanently and therefore legally being
able to take upon him the consequences
of that human race taking those
consequences upon himself becoming sin
for us Jesus taught the same thing in
John chapter 3 when he says as the
serpent was lifted up in the woman in
the wilderness so must the son of man be
lifted up that whosoever believeth on
him should not perish but have eternal
amen
Hallelujah
okay now we have this question thank you
James from Oklahoma a text from Donna
this question is was the wine Jesus made
at the wedding an alcoholic wine
chandensi please
this is a second wine question yes so we
have uh okay John chapter 8 verse 45 and
46 is what I began where it says but
because I tell the truth you do not
believe me which of you convicts me of
sin and if I tell you the truth why do
you not believe me Jesus is talking to
the scribes and Pharisees and those that
were constantly after him to try to find
something wrong with Jesus but Jesus
says which of you convicts me of sin
they were watching him now notice what
it says in Proverbs chapter 20 verse 1
again I quote wanting to say mocker
strong drink is a brawler and whoever's
LED astray by it is not wise had Jesus
At The Feast created alcoholic beverage
they would have pinned him down and said
hey you are teaching something against
the scriptures and so uh notice what it
says in John 2 10 concerning what Jesus
did and he said to him every man at the
beginning sets out the good wine and
when the guests have well drunk then the
inferior you have kept the good wine
until now the best grape juice was left
for last is what he's trying to say
again the context determines what it's
talking about fermented or unfermented
now I quote to you from Jewish tradition
Jewish tradition strongly spoke out
against using alcoholic wine at Festival
occasions including weddings I read to
you from some writings it says the
talmud indicates that drinking to the
accompaniment of musical instruments on
Festival occasions such as a wedding was
forbidden the latter is confirmed by
testimonies of rabbis for example Rabbi
SM Isaac and eminent 19th century Rabbi
and editor of the Jewish messenger says
the Jews do not in their feast for
sacred purposes including the marriage
Feast ever use any kind of fermented
drinks in their oblations and Libations
both private and public they employed
the fruit of the vine that is fresh
grapes unfermented grape juice and
raisins as a symbol of benediction
fermentation is to them always a symbol
of corruption so would Jesus do this
would he bring fermented no he had
unfermented grape juice there and Mayo
Clinic says alcohol is dangerous to your
brain I can't quote it because my time
is up well actually we're going to go to
a break but when we come back please
finish your statement okay so folks
we'll be right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3ab in Bible q a for answers from
God's word
well thank you for joining us once again
for the last moments of this hour John
deziko to please finish your answer well
Mayo Clinic has this to say and it's
interesting listen yeah alcohol is a
neurotoxin that can disrupt
Communications of the brain it also
affects functions of our brain cells
directly and indirectly through
different organ dysfunction from alcohol
usage and vitamin deficiency depending
on the area of the brain affected people
can have different symptoms abusing
alcohol can lead to seizure stroke and
dementia to name a few conditions so
question would Jesus really offer
fermented wine at a wedding even at the
beginning of his ministry absolutely not
it was fresh grape juice thank you Lord
bless you my husband Lord bless you that
was beautiful thank you so much yes
thank you James for joining us and God
bless you as well in your ministry and
Jason thank you so much do you guys have
any words to say to our viewers well I
want to touch on the sin part for a
second you know whatever you've done
whatever you've gone through Jesus is
standing there he's waiting for you to
go to him amen you know here's the thing
he already knows what you did so you
might as well confess it with a sincere
heart repent turn away amen and uh turn
towards God resist the devil and he will
flee from you but God wants to hear from
you and he's longing with for a
relationship with you he wants to spend
eternity with you so do everything that
you can give it to him give it hand it
over to God he does all the heavy
lifting amen and he wants to talk with
you amen James I'm just but I want to
close with that thought because I just
think that is so powerful and beautiful
amen praise the lord we have a savior
amen praise the lord well let not
anything hinder you from coming to
Christ because he extends his Loving
Arms towards you and the invitation is
continual may the Lord bless you as he
continue to study his word amen
[Music]
thank you